[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui allez vous le savez nous
sommes bien en direct dans cette
émission on le dit depuis le début parce
qu'il ya des gens voilà il ya des
rumeurs causent qui sortent comme quand
on dépend on dirait que je ne sais pas
des gens sont fous où va le monde
alors on va te tue t'appeler un
restaurant chez patton pour leur
demander leurs seins et pour prouver
qu'on est dans le direct on appelle tout
de suite chez patoche ces particules
tout doute de tout on tue tous deux chez
patton si on verra partir de 19h30 c'est
à quand donc a priori c'est ouvert
attention deuxième sonnerie alors oui
toi oui je suis bien sûr pas tâche
exactement salut patassé cyril hanouna
comment il va bien il va super bien
alors qu'est-ce qui prépare ce soir-là
au resto qu'est ce qui se prépare dans
la sphère grand monde
c'est fait le problème c'est pas vrai
talent mais il est un peu tôt quand même
bon bah j'en vois des gens d'accord il
est qu'elle est bien trop vite en moins
qu'un gros buts en moins car et un petit
salut par 45 voix
merci papote
jkk emprunt soit l'os malaire également
et c'est toi le mec de valérie bénaïm
oui d'ailleurs jérôme quelques foule ce
soir là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et ben non patoche je te l'envoie c'est
mon cadeau plaisir merci patachon moi
c'est très fort chez les passionnés
l'attend pour moi est à moi salue pas
touche pas tous un pathos et ben voilà